[Music]
Oh makes me want to dance does it make
you want to dance the Backstreet Boys
are definitely larger than life in Las
Vegas they just added 15 more shows to
their residency at Planet Hollywood
they're doing such a fantastic job but
Nick Carter has a few other things
keeping him really busy right now like a
new TV show and being a dad
Nick talked about it all with DT online
Lianne Aguilera
[Applause]
you are a father yourself now if you're
a little boy were to come to you in a
decade or so and be like dad I want to
be in a boy band I want to be like you
what would you say to him I'm already
expecting it to happen okay to be fair
little Oden his only 14 months old but
he already likes to bust a move
just like his Backstreet Boy dad's I
just got to support him you know and and
guide him and and the right things to do
and hopefully because that's the thing
about the entertainment business it can
be dangerous at times and if you're not
supported by your family you can get in
trouble with playing games with my Nick
is now 37 years old and still performing
in Vegas with the guys but he's also
pulling double duty Nick is an architect
basically a coach on ABC's new music
competition show boy band
[Music]
on the series Nick baby spice Emma
Bunton Timbaland and host Rita Ora try
to find the guys will be the next
backstreet Nick might be the perfect
coach because he was just 13 when his
boy band took off what would you say was
your role in the Backstreet Boys back
then and what is it now I guess it kind
of started pretty then I went a little
bad and then I got I got a little more
mature a little bit more responsible now
so I went through all the phases of
every single boy we got Nick to show off
his coaching skills
a nothin but a heart heart all right and
then rolled by
[Music]